wenn euch etwas essbares auf den boden
fällt denn irland das die bakterien
polizei kommt laut stopp schreibt und
fünf zählt wissenschaftler haben jetzt
das experiment gemacht und wassermelone
butterbrot und gummibärchen auf
verschiedenen bühnen geschmissen
es ist zwar schon so dass immer mehr
bakterien an bord springt länger das
essen darum liegt allerdings brauchen
wir uns nichts vorzumachen weniger als
einer sekunde ist das essen schon
bevölkert also nichts mit fünf sekunden
bei der wassermelone erreicht man in
dieser kurzen zeit sogar schon maximal
befall da die bakterien eigentlich nicht
wirklich springen sondern er schwimmen
deswegen je feuchter das essen desto
schlimmer
die größte überraschung aber wenn man
glatte bodenflächen mit teppichboden
vergleicht dann ist es sich vom teppich
am besten die bakterien kommen von der
rauen teppich oberfläche schlechter weg
außerdem ist die kontaktfläche bei
teppich kleiner als bei glatten
oberflächen also fünf sekunden regel
gestratz aber bei all der theorie gilt
auch ein paar keime sind gut fürs
immunsystem schon klar
[Musik]